60 minutes correspondent John Dickerson
is here with a look at what the
impeachment inquiry means for the 2020
election John always good to have you
here you know very interesting time for
us because you've got for the first time
a president who's running for
re-election who's also facing an
impeachment inquiry so is there a way
that both sides can use this to their
advantage oh sure and they're gonna
there's two upsides and downsides for
the Democrats it's a chance the upside
is to define the president define what
they think he did wrong in the specific
instance and more broadly downside as
they look vindictive they look like
they're warping an honored institution
for the purpose of just trying to get
him out of office for Republicans the
problem for them the downside for them
is that they shred the traditional
American values you saw it in some of
the defense of the president with with
Alexander Bittman the lieutenant colonel
in the Army when some of the president's
defenders basically said he had dual
loyalties that was going too far the
upside for Republicans is that they get
a chance to define Democrats through the
impeachment process when you have an
unpopular president and this president
is unpopular what you often try to do is
basically tear down the other party and
so it's an opportunity for Republicans
not only to defend the president but
also to characterize the Democrats this
is more partisan than ever John which is
what's really striking about this I mean
you go back to Nixon and I think it was
all but for Republicans voted to move
forward in the impeachment there were 31
Democrats with Clinton who voted to move
to impeach no Republicans on the on this
recent vote right we are in a more
tribal period now where the structure of
politics incentivizes people to close
ranks in Nixon's time you had senators
from parties whose voters voted for
Nixon for president but they were
Democrats and so those same voters had
voted for them so boaters were switching
parties you had split ticket voting
that's almost gone now and so you have
an instance in which you have voters who
are much more tribally aligned and the
media landscape is different so you have
people going to their preferred media
outlets seeking affirmation rather than
information what a president Trump's
many responses to the impeachment threat
has been look the economy's doing great
if you impeach me it's gonna crash so
how important is the economy to his
reelection first of all that as a
sitting president is a great argument
right because they can say something
simply and you can say you may not like
my methods in the way I
but hey the economy's doing well so he's
got a good argument that's traditionally
been a good argument but this is not a
traditional president and we see a gap
between the way people think the economy
is going and the way they think he is
behaving as president and that's why for
Democrats in the course of impeachment
and the election their argument is to
say sure the economy is important but
there are downsides to a disordered
presidency and here they are a B and C
and that's their sort of key argument
for the next year between now and the
election and develop on that is there's
so much bigger than the impeachment
question it's a great happening here yes
what happens when you have an
impeachment going on while you have a
reelection is it's a chance for the
country to look at the presidency and
say how do we want a president to behave
should they listen to experts or should
they go around and create their own
foreign policy channel how do they sort
their priorities is the president paying
attention to the most important thing in
the world when he's talking to the
Ukraine president or is he focused only
on his set of priorities which are
different from the countries those kinds
of debates about the larger role of the
presidency are all on the table now now
we can all get distracted by the food
fight in an impeachment or we can step
back and say what are the standards of a
presidency is this president exceeding
those standards falling below them and
what are the costs and we've never had a
chance to be able to do that have that
larger conversation about the presidency
with the most significant point of
debate between the Democratic
frontrunner of this point seems to be
over health care do you think that's
gonna be the deciding factor here in the
nominee it's a proxy debate in a way
which is to say whether Medicare for all
actually is ever gonna happen is not as
important is as I get a signal from a
candidate who's showing me their
commitment on that issue when Donald
Trump said the Mexicans are gonna pay
for the wall that was never gonna happen
his voters knew it was never gonna
happen but they thought that sends me a
signal about how committed he is to that
idea that's really what Medicare for all
is as a debate because think about what
a promo Kratt ik president will face
when they come into office let's imagine
they get elected they will have been
elected as a restoration of the American
presidency a Democrat that's going to be
a busy job there's going to be a lot to
do most of it oversees the political
landscape will have been beaten by a
year of politics getting
medicare-for-all passed through the
Senate or doing it even through
reconciliation or some you know clever
method is going to be extremely
difficult because they're gonna be so
busy doing
and politics will be a much even coarser
place than it is now so the conversation
they're having is really about a proxy
for things less about what actually is
gonna be able to happen with a Democrat
one fares this is gonna get a coarser
and more partisan before it gets less so
it's in everybody's interest to get it
course more course and to keep their
bases aligned at the moment John
Dickerson thank you very much